all right so okay everyone game please
ready hello and welcome to the weekly
poll as usual I'm Benny for the comics
torreón and this week our guardians of
the galaxy has finally finished up its
original sin we've got Harley Quinn's
you Gretchen sniffing - sniffing - we
got part act 1 part 6 of godhead with
Sinestro we've got a new issue of saga
carnage has an individual issue all-new
x-men has Miles Morales fighting the
only x-men we've got what the hell is
this a bloated World's End character
futures end has Batman sewn onto the
Joker Batman eternal Hinds was fighting
off with mush death the Wolverine has
got a sequel involving Captain America
and Deadpool this is Aquaman getting a
crown and I missed it last week but
Batman has the awesome bat suit I am
Benny for comics Torian that is Sal for
TV little house and that is Rob mystery
guest was arrived today so if you look
you guys wanted me to do the Mario voice
to them but open-cell voice lessons
really came in handy they did guys this
is trailer Drake one of the newest
members of the comic book Avengers what
you fail on that one console yeah that's
what we're calling her so I guess your
Black Widow yeah yeah I mean look
obvious where the comic book adventures
he is running the comicdrake channel but
you may remember his voice from
unpopular opinions about popular video
games over on his trailer J channel he
also does I that one he does a lot of on
the camera stuff
and he's also the voice-over head game
theory that does crossover everybody's
favorite show from what I've read and
smash history the show that he does
don't entirely hate me sometimes why you
always promote cross cross over as the
show everyone hates I like crossover I
cross over I acknowledge that nobody's
invited but hey it gets views yeah I
really like making it and writing
researching it no I I enjoy watching and
I've seen it a few times although I will
admit the very first time that I saw it
I was like that's not Matt that what is
it now
hello internet welcome to game theory
the show the blank blank blank blank
blank blank are you like anybody you
would actually do his voice perfect why
thank you I've been trying really hard
so that I can pass off my show as Matt
pad all right guys so as usual anybody
who is a usual viewer of us I don't know
how many people came over here from my
twitch followers or how many people are
here from the actual tweets out I don't
know maybe Rob tweeted this out maybe
Rob didn't but yeah unless you're blind
Rob is not here this week and the reason
for that is he has personal family
issues if you go to his channel he does
explain it a little bit better but I
don't feel it's our place to explain
that for him
no but if you're watching this it is
going up when Marvel explain meaning
you're probably watching this over there
if you're one of Rob's fans so he will
be back as soon as you can and until
he's back it'll be myself and Sal um and
maybe trailer Drake will join us on a
weekly basis until police you know you
guys don't hate me we got to know each
other pretty well over the last 45
minutes of Tron is that if the
commenters don't like me I am more than
happy to take the boot and leave but I'm
hope that I'm enough they haven't liked
me since the first episode so they're
either really hate you and if you're
wondering my Rover hunt which we've
discovered today at the Sal doesn't know
what technology is he is further in the
dark ages and robbed pretty party I will
say this the the YouTube interface for
live events is a disaster and this is a
problem that I have every time we've
done like three live events and each
time it's a together to get it actually
working to get it we're always like 20
to 40 minutes late and it just it I
don't know it's like a miracle that it
actually winds up working I know but but
I will say this um we are working on it
and since everyone does seem to enjoy
this podcast that's proven by the views
over at Rob's channel we are working out
a way to make this more professional
make this more on topic and make this
better and more appropriate and we have
a new location that's gonna be hosted
very very soon and when that happens
we'll let you guys all know do you know
what
that's right our drink doesn't know what
it is
you guys should tell me what it is so I
was solar gonna talk about some comic
books today no no we're not doing that
we don't talk about comics here this is
actually all about the Fox in your
background oh okay reading ding in a
crack aah crack aah crack ow
oh no yeah okay so we're gonna go ahead
and talk about the one thing that
everyone is talking about at the comic
book world Marvel has released
officially their plans until 2019 yeah
enough when DC did it yeah I know it
deep boy yeah but you know what DC
didn't like a month in advance DC DC
like Marvel made a big extravaganza for
DC was just kind of like look we got
well I think it was I think that's
actually in response to the fact that
like that whole DC lineup was leaked
like a few weeks before they did it oh
yeah knows people were like hey here's
the Aquaman movie here's like the cyborg
movie like they got every that they had
their ducks in a row and the whole
internet was like speculating about what
they were gonna do with the movies
before DS even announced they existed
and I think Warner Bros and DC had a
very like typical movie studio response
which was like oh well then okay yeah
list and Marvel is more like an Apple
summit where they're like look at this
wonderful stuff we've got going on you
might not give a crap but we guarantee
you by the time it comes out you will
yeah yeah yeah they really gave him
really nice keynote I I wanna say I'm
excited for everything they announced
yeah everything that Marvel has put out
that I like in that list I'm like yep
I'm in look if they make guardians of
the galaxy work they could make any
moving work I wouldn't be surprised if
we see a Squirrel Girl movie and it'd be
the best bit of the best movie that if
we guarantee you man squirrel needs to
be like a pig so I know she's getting a
movie a comic series she's getting a
solo series getting a very new solo by
the way I read the preview it looks like
garbage but no all they need to do is
have Scotty young do it I think it'd be
good to go oh my god Scotty young it's
like somebody that's like a perfect
Scott a young book people who don't have
Scotty youngest he's doing the new
the brand-new version of a rocket racoon
and he's got a very unique art style
bags then we talking about this guy
right yes laying around for Free Comic
Book Day yeah it's it's not very good
you don't like it no we're on issue for
now it's two really silly I got the
first one with loot crate and I was like
ass alright it's not for me
if there's one thing I don't like it's
all the random silly crazy stuff like
Deadpool and Harley Quinn it's not for
me
no I own decibel and I say I won't ask
your bid on that cuz I never you never
responded after watching the video
before Marvel pulled it off my channel
this still wasn't for you after seeing
like the softer side of get bull if
anything does interest me it's gonna be
a Deadpool's book of war art of war
whenever he's creating his own book uh
the guy that works my little comic shop
he'd even write down okay that sounds
like it's not terrible right okay I'll
give it a try but I mean like I'm so
sick of just being wall wall wall random
chimichangas banana duck that's just
what's what I get from all of his books
I'm pretty sure I'm the only guy on the
entire show that what that reads
Deadpool on a consistent basis yes you
are correct okay so uh why don't we
start from the beginning of the list and
we'll go through that okay and we'll run
down our usual tangents and our crazy
stuff and go on God said never be a
topic like always
um can we we need to enter Rob's memory
and Rob's memory is to discuss something
and then jump into an obscure character
that no one knows anything about it's
been 20 minutes announcing them now
here's the thing let me give you a
five-minute rant on the best hero that
you've never heard of Booster Gold oh
you did that Booster Gold a lot of my
channel and people are like hey some guy
with a Booster Gold avatar commented he
was like hey I'm like Booster Gold is
awesome and you know what I will say
this I thought it was a joke and to the
light did there was a script for that
video and I was like he's actually cool
Bennie ask you like hey what do you want
a voice Booster Gold
sure that's gonna take some research
I'll get to that in a minute
no we as Booster Gold fans are very
small in numbers but we are passionate
and I mean you see that my background is
Booster Gold and then the background
after that is him and Blue Beetle and I
just ordered Blue Beetle number one in
Booster Gold number one to hopefully
have friend now are you excited that
about a potential continuation of the
Booster Gold storyline with the yes
three new 52 the new 52 the older Brooke
Booster Gold and of course his son
reporter yes now here's the big thing I
mainly just wonderfully go on a tangent
by mentioning an obscure character and I
was so right yeah totally
yeah we took it we actually did it yeah
no you're filling his role quite nicely
that's okay what happened here okay
so the first movie on the list announced
at the summit was hold on where the crap
is it age of Ultron okay let's all we
know what Angelo's done at this point I
even made a video about the Hulkbuster
armor at this point he did a funny
trailer with everybody trying to pull
Thor's hammer and cat maybe go a little
bit and we're not really upset about
that yeah I mean it looked wonderful I'm
sick of everything every trailer going
no strings on me no here's my question
though did you read the age of Ultron
actual storyline nope I know you did it
now because I was involved in that
Twitter like discussion you had of
didn't cover that I really thought I did
and it turns out we didn't ever sort of
tangents about it and that's really how
much it's worth
Ultron like let me give you a quick
summary of age of Ultron okay Ultron
kills everyone and then he doesn't
that's really I was ready for spoilers
and here's the problem is the age of
Ultron comic book story I can tell you
right now will have nothing to do with
them oh no it has no inch ya know
because the Ultron story is totally
contingent on the continuity of like
Hank Pym creating Ultron and a alternate
future and then another alternate future
neither of which exist or will exist
right so yeah it's it basically
the story starts like 10 years in the
future at the beginning so we know it's
in the present no no before that is not
in the present it has to totally that's
me at least 6 months in the future at
least no it's not it's not like that was
Bendis this whole thing right age of
Ultron is Ultron kills everybody today
that's that's how the comic series goes
he kills everyone today the point is
that they need to go to the Future to
stop him because he's sending people
from the future to the Past that's the
comic series which is this is this is
why they'll never do it ok in the comic
series the Ultron is sending he's in the
future he's sending people in the past
to kill people the Fantastic Four and
Wolverine have to devise a plan so right
off the bat the main stars are not gonna
be in the movie you know yeah the main
cast is owned by Fox right sue Richards
in Wolverine and of going in the past
because Wolverines plan is to kill Hank
Pym who in the age of Ultron movie did
not make Ultron because he hasn't been
introduced yet it's kind of hinted at
the Iron Man makes the early stuff shows
that it's a Jarvis like takeover kind of
a deal I thought it was gonna be well
the theory that I have is that they're
rushing to get ant-man
out because while Hank Pym won't be
chiefly responsible for creating Ultron
in the movie universe it could be that
like Hank Pym invented Ultron but was
too advanced like I don't have all the
components I need but one day this ultra
Stark will find it because of his ties
with shield maybe like it'll be a
throwback to when he stole all the dirty
secrets of shield in the first Avengers
movie and then he'll be like oh I can do
this better and then him being like and
I learned a lesson I can't make
everything better well in the comic
series what ends up happening is the
entire Avengers crew except for Sue
Richards Wolverine goes to the future to
fight against Ultron in the future
because they don't want to alter the
timestream yeah and what ends up
happening is they all die so Hoover a
mr. Richards go in the past to try and
kill Hank Pym they do and they discover
the world is ten times worse than it was
with the old from taking over like yeah
well people are just all kinds of messed
up so he goes back in the past again
kills himself from killing Hank Pym now
he stops it well he convinces himself
not to kill him and then in order to
preserve the
I'm line he's like we can't have two
Wolverines running around so 1 Wolverine
kills the other wolf but they don't sure
how he did it because technically
Wolverine can't die
oh no we they don't think it's pretty
obvious what he does well they go like
this I think he chops his own head off
well so anyway well no then we
discovered he doesn't use body anyway
that's another story
so so then we go back to the future the
futures been fixed but what they did it
did a snapback effect on the timestream
which then led into many of the more
stories coming out everyone else in
angel becoming to the Marvel Universe
stuff like that New Avengers infinity
also came out of the fact that Wolverine
went back in time is snapped to the
timeline cuz we've like apparently
Marvel's been going back in time like
since the beginning of time like we've
been [ __ ] with the time story forever
so it's Ultron so I'm extremely confused
I appreciate it don't worry because age
of Ultron has nothing to do with
anything
right exactly which is the one was gonna
make like they couldn't use the main
characters they couldn't go
you couldn't on the second movie kill
off the entire Avengers cat no that's so
stupid the port is so dark they wouldn't
do that I mean they're I know you're
going darker yeah it's gonna be dark
yeah but to go to the point of mass
murdering everyone yeah I mean at least
Avengers 3 whenever they're getting
ready for the New Avengers team to take
over yeah big moneymaker yeah now we
talked about now let's let's get into
that because like the the not even rumor
I guess like the official word is that
like after hundreds dude there's gonna
be a whole new roster yep which is in
line with the Avengers history because I
don't know if Drake if you know like the
Avengers that he's like everyone what
associate SCAP Iron Man and Thor with
the Avengers that's like that's the
Avengers but it's not always been the
Avengers and even it's always been like
a rotating piston also which Avengers
are we talking about there is Avengers
they're Secret Avengers there's dark
Avenger oh yeah that's the only recent
cuz of the movies oh yeah forwardly for
that it was like the Avengers was the
roster of people they did to go hold a
book yeah well those people those are
characters that couldn't hold a book
either back arms the Holy Trinity and
and much like how DC is Superman Batman
you have you have your uh your lawful
good you've got your technology guy and
then you've got the mythical and that's
kind of what they've all been and every
thinks that Iron Man has been this huge
star and he really hasn't until now
movies made him popular yes oh you're
100% right about that as matter of fact
Iron Man's stories before they took a
benefit I read stories when he became
popular we're still in completely
garbage iron man runs into the problem
that Hulk runs into we're with the Hulk
he's so strong you can't make a good
story because he does that's why in
civil war the Glassman to space because
whichever side has it wins
exactly exactly reason why he's there
but the problem of Tony Stark is he can
just invent his way out of anything
that's the problem a lot of the super
intelligent guys I mean Reed Richards
has the same issue that's and that's
also why I think they invented the
Illuminati in the comic series because
that removes all of the super
intelligence well it also makes them
interesting you don't know what the
Illuminati I'm gonna cover this real
soon a comic story so you're getting a
spoiler everybody here okay the
Illuminati is made up of all the most
intelligent people and the most
prominent people in the comics so it's
it's Tony Stark it's Black Panther it's
Hank Pym like that was enjoy the
aluminum the incursians oh yeah yeah
what happened in the road to Civil War
yes yes they got created from that
they're still around and they make
incisions to mess of everyone now the
decisions that they're making in the
comics right now and everyone's against
because it's turned to all of these
characters into bad guys is in the
comics there's these incursions the
Earth's are colliding together and it
destroys both earths so in order to save
our earth the Illuminati has been going
to the other world and literally
destroying them yeah huh so what the
dark which turns everyone into these
villains and when they finally had to
blow up a planet which by the way was
the planet that a makeshift version of
the Justice League came from which was
funny like they all like it was like
they they kind of flipped over yeah
come yet actually really quick real
quick cuz the comment says I play come
to Melbourne yours I do play Marvel
heroes but we're only flagging this
because there's no comic book podcast
option that's which but uh you know it's
speaking of you know the Illuminati
being in the rodents of war Captain
America 3 is civil exactly yes and I
think that's why they're trying to rush
all these other characters out
that there is a bigger or isn't like
dance poor characters well you know what
let's talk about that real quick does
captain variance are the ninety sounded
amazing will they launch Hulk into space
because either way who wins we don't
know I think yes I think they are
because there's no Hulk movie yep
and so the launch of launch min to space
let him sit out for a little bit
recast as they need to like to do every
other movie and then we have I think we
could easily get a Planet Hulk movie and
I think the fact that Gardens the galaxy
where it did so well I think in Boldin's
Marvel to be able to do that
oh yeah their entire cosmic universe is
up on the table now yeah I think they're
like man it would be cool to do a Planet
Hulk movie just gladiator with the Hulk
in it and like the only thing is it
would cost a lot because you'd have to
have the Hulk in the movie the whole
time yeah in hulked out - yeah blow in
it like ever the world they could easily
write that off I mean oh yeah he's just
Mark Ruffalo until he needs to fight you
know the guys right but here's the
question I wanted to ask about that so
Captain America's serpent society which
as we know is actually civil war because
I got told over there to hold it or not
yeah it was a joke oh really yeah oh it
was a joke guys just one can American
movie I thought it really was serving
society I'm like alright they joked
about it attention civil war but this
leads me to my question we're not doing
a venture savour we're doing Captain
America Civil War yeah and that doesn't
appear to be any more tires so a black
panther who's gonna be in it well yeah
but a what I'm saying is it's not black
panther Civil War it's Black Panther
which means that the Civil War plotline
will probably be mostly contained in the
Captain America yeah so what can we
really expect out of the Civil War
uh well they said that Tony Stark Iron
Man will be in a big part of Civil War
so well of Captain America Civil Wars
alright
I'm guessing it'll be a civil war
between the two of them like maybe
asleep between them with a few cameos
from the other cast members already yeah
I think we'll probably see like I mean
will WC Falcon and we'll see like what
you think that they're using this to not
basically not because I know that I know
that they're playing some loophole games
to keep people on the contracts longer
yeah do you think that this is Captain
America Civil War instead of being
Avengers
or to do just that play some loophole
games and get a Captain America movie
out there but it really is more the
Avengers Civil War it could it could be
but a big thing is that if they are
planning on moving on to a different
cast for another Avengers we all know
that after Civil War
Captain America dies I'm sorry to the
five of you who didn't read civil war
that was literally on the news so
Captain America died and [ __ ] he's
back and now he's old and but this is a
great way to tie into maybe Falcon
taking over because he's been
established in the universe and that we
have a different Captain America playing
in the Captain America role for the New
Avengers movies because he's still gonna
sell a lot of toys and Disney wants to
sell a lot of toys yeah oh and then if
they could make they could do the winner
they could go to the Winter Soldier
route and have Bucky Barnes take over as
Captain America they could skip him I
just go to Anthony man either way two
options yeah they can so can Captain
Merrick around and still have the heavy
factor of like oh [ __ ] we killed Captain
America and yeah well yeah but you know
what I would like them to keep them dead
if they do it instead of just yeah sure
warning aback because if they're you
can't get but a Chris Evans this is
that's the proof let's just actually get
rid of Chris Evans you know and Chris
Evans wants to move on to directing
anyway and so this will be this will be
a great way to do it I really think that
by having a falcon taking over we'll see
how the Black Panther movie does because
there isn't a huge we don't really know
how an African American superheroes
going to work in today's market like
we've had steel we've had blade but
ladies wait yeah and in today's new
comic book centric movie universe we
don't know how long african-american
character will do so if black character
does really well we might see Falcon
take over but if not we might see the
Bucky Barnes route and then nobody's
gonna say no to that Disney Marvel movie
money so yeah I mean I think there's
multiple ways that we can see characters
come back even characters all together
yeah but but we're not gonna see where I
don't think we're gonna get anyone back
when we remove them finally that's
that's an upset cuz due to age we're not
really gonna bring back a 40-year old
Chris Evans to be exactly this isn't
gonna be oral sorts inators the turn
again and just go ahead and pretend he
still look young if you killed Captain
America's Captain America Civil War and
then wanted to bring him back for
Avengers the infinity war you could use
one of the gems yeah it is soon enough
and they'll probably at least once pull
that that I think they were do I think
that'll be one holy [ __ ] they brought
him back mama yeah they won't do it for
every Super we're not gonna get normal
comical continuity where people get
removed all the time and then there's
back like a week later right well every
movie has to have their big holy [ __ ]
moment we know for a fact that taps
gonna use Thor's hammer and they made it
so obvious whenever heat wished they
wouldn't even had that opening scene but
wasn't establishing that hey there's a
possibility we all know that kept is
worthy of it but only when he has the
warrior spirit so when he is fighting
Ultron I guarantee he's gonna be using
Thor's hammer oh yeah these big holy
[ __ ] moments will be the big thing his
shield is cracked so he's gonna need
something and you know it's gonna be
amazing
the cartoon method and they give him
that like hologram shield that that's
stupid whatever show Avengers my hero is
fun because there's a cartoon we don't
have to explain how you make a solid
hologram unless you're wrong didn't see
coming though was the Captain Marvel
movie
that's it I'm hoping for forever and I'm
so glad to see it's finally well you
know what I'm surprised about cuz I got
a lot of this in the comments people
don't want the female Captain Marvel
they wanted Marvel Oh awesome yeah no I
think what they wanted Marvin Marvel
like wanted Carol Danvers every video I
think dominus on every Marvel or video
related to this but they're having a
Captain Marvel movie the next movie that
follows it is Inhumans if they're
obviously setting up a Miss Marvel movie
because she she is on her seventh
printing right now she is she is
so popular sheet dump teamed up with
Wolverine she teamed up with with a
spider-man in his own amazing spider-man
comic not a team-up comic actually
insider's book yeah that was isn't
inhuman yep she she isn't inhuman she
idolizes Captain Marvel and I think that
another female led movie would be a huge
selling point and it's gonna be the
first Pakistani American superhero on
life web screen big screen ever there's
also another if they bring in miss
marble you get a teenage superhero they
can finally start making like I mean I
know the superhero movies aren't
entirely aimed at adults that kind of in
the teen age I'd say they're morally
like 17 older crowd they're aiming a mat
with the you know with some kid you know
that's what they're kind of aiming about
everyone sees them but you don't I mean
and I have a feeling that if they do do
miss Marvel Base marble the the teenage
girl who goes to school and everything
they're gonna start trying to break into
doing kind of teenage tweenage kind of
movies like you know it'll be a lower
scale of like you know darkness and
everything I mean works for me yeah yeah
I would love to see like a run yeah I
yeah you know I'm gonna be like I
haven't read it and told her team up
with spider-man and I was like wow he's
really good yeah that was probably I
like tell spider my take that role of a
throw right kid I'll show you how to do
this you know yeah I preferred I liked
the art on the Wolverine book as opposed
to the regular artist on Miss Marvel but
uh yeah they said nobody's talking about
it and they are so obviously setting up
Miss Marvel movie it could not be any
more obvious be cool they I can see that
potential there because this is phase 3
once we go through the infinity war red
phase what's it for
oh yeah but yeah cuz they're actually
doing it a little bit this is something
I didn't catch until right now and we
can go ahead and cuz you're discussing
in humans we have infinity War part 1
then the Inhumans then infinity War part
jus that's true and then marble oh no we
have Captain Marvel and Inhumans between
the infinity Wars yeah exactly
yeah yeah no I think nobody's talking
about it it's so obvious yeah I think
that Captain Marvel shows that Avengers
or yeah I think captain Marvel's gonna
show up in Avengers and then they'll
make movie so that it's like a vehicle
like it's like all the people who like
to windows guardians to come out
yeah hold on does that kind of break it
up and you're got a few second lag on
you so just you want to drop the caller
fast sorry again it's just connection to
shizzle okay but when does guardians of
the galaxy to come out in relation to
the infinity war uh it's the exact same
day you're ahead yeah okay well so
captain Marvel's been doing a lot of
teams with the guardians in the comics
and stuff so why not introduce her there
that's a good point I could say that
yeah the energies are there then we go
to store and we go through back Black
Panther which is the black panther one
is the black camera loop yeah
well black Nico's gonna be introduced in
Civil War and then gonna have the Black
Panther movie right here's a black
panther just hang up real fast there
just come right back in just a click
okay should clear up your connection
that's why yes okay okay no see well
here's something here's something here's
it blows my mind about the Black Panther
thing I want to say this real quick
Black Panther is the only superhero on
this list that I'm looking at right now
that doesn't have a book right now and
if he does that it's been hidden in my
store forever right now he I know he's
in the Avengers a lot he's in the
Illuminati a lot he's a part of the
Illuminati and he'll see what pops up a
lot but he doesn't hold his own book
down no makes sense yeah but then again
like most of these characters like Iron
Man I haven't liked an Iron Man title in
a long time I don't know in the core
units of the galaxy no it's true
so like ya know uh I liked him in that
little crossover and they'd pretty much
Pokemon in him the whole time
yeah Tony we have better technology than
you like I think the greatest line ever
it was when he was thought he was
recording a message saying thank you to
the guardians of the galaxy and it goes
like
new pages of thank-yous and you guys are
great and it gets to the end of the
whole thing music so how do I send this
thing off and like Tony you're live we
just walk you out whole thing Iraq it's
like you're not did you think you were
it's a phone yeah I think that we're
gonna see Black Panther actually in this
movie and in Ultron I don't know if he's
gonna be a character but I think you're
gonna I think we're gonna see what Conda
and I think we'll probably did lead to
some kind of reference to him what maybe
we could have all done awaken in Wakanda
wakanda's known for having technology
far beyond every maybe that's where Tony
gets the peace maybe you're right maybe
he does get Hank pins Ultron and he has
to go to a Conda to get the additional
technology yeah he brings it in or
Ultron knows that there's some tech that
he needs notre to take over the world
that he knows is from Wakanda which is
it because they've always got a bomb
over there for some reason always got a
super bomb yeah of course I don't know
why wakanda's always got that but every
story I read so he's black brothers like
now um really quick we were talking
about the movies themselves and some one
of the Chad mentioned what about
villains and I'm kind of excited all at
that
okay well villains well obviously we
know it's civil where the villains are
going to be the superheroes fighting
against each other
that's the courting we may see like a
spin of Red Skull just pushing it
somehow or whatever I mean like we've
been it's been a long time that we
haven't seen Red Skull and we know Hugo
Weaving doesn't want to be Red Skull
anymore no he doesn't
oh he just wanted the one move me up and
they were in Marvel's like well we have
you for a three-picture deal and he's
like whatever the fine is I'll just pay
it I don't want to do it I'm like I'm
Lord of the Rings but uh I need my
matron money I was Agent Smith I'll have
you know so I don't need either whistles
for three movies I'm like I don't want
to see Red Skull for three movies that
works out fine for me okay well then a
dr. strange I don't know anything about
dr. strange outside of his core stuff so
who was the Doctor Strange expert I
don't know anything about dr. strange
but I did buy a trade because I have
always been interested in the sorcerer
supreme I don't really care
how they in making movie how they do any
of the [ __ ] as long as they play
people are strange whenever they have
his I'm learning my powers the gun Oh so
we have no idea what film dr. snow it's
gonna be it's gonna be either Mordo or
doctor or it's gonna be either Mordo
who's like a anti dr. strange is like
another of the few of the ancient ones
pupils okay or it'll be the ruler of
whatever the hell door ma'am Oh who was
like a baby I know him from Marvel vs.
Capcom you play video the Drake he looks
like the Headless Horseman Ghost Rider
oh okay
like with a pumpkin head he looks for
time guardians of the galaxy to who what
are we thinking because they set up an
oh yeah oh yeah I'm thinking retelling
the strings of something yeah Thor
Ragnarok I have no idea what's gonna go
what more and we've already hit the big
Thor villains I think I mean what was
the book like cuz there was a big
thought I think they're gonna kill for
in that one by the way yeah
why hmm I could even kill for worried
the new Thor
hmm I don't know if they're gonna get I
don't know if they're gonna fast-track
female Thor why not I just feel like the
comic girl we don't even know who he
still sells tickets and what if it is
his mom and his mom just picks up like
she's no spoilers for Thor too but she
did well yeah okay that's really
interesting yet cuz uh right she's the
all mother and she was she's at least to
my knowledge still rolling Asgard right
now uh she just there's a little over
and let it go because Odin's back yeah
well she didn't roll over I let it go
yet they're pretty much fighting about
it right now they're like well he's like
I'm still in charge music oh the old
father is back you wanna sing for me I
will do it's really weird and
misogynistic you will do what our same
woman you what go cook me food oh I
think I think the over cammed
be misogynistic aspect to that because
it's a new female Thor
yeah yeah I mean that might have been
why they were doing it over the top so
that when the female Thor comes in we
already expect to be she can do what
she's not to be Odin son but just like
oh right we've seen enough of that yet
where it's like she can't do it she's a
woman do we need that at this point like
haven't we really what comics are
getting to the point where there is a
lot more of diversity and equality in
genders races sexualities and video
games still the long way to go until
they get to that point and comics they
really had their big testosterone filled
things that was the 90s and they're like
the goddesses in comics but I really do
think that we're seeing this huge rise
of the female superhero being taken more
seriously we have Miss Marvel Captain
Marvel Thor Black Widow all these that's
just horrible that's quite a few as well
yeah I think that I was making a giant
push to be the first guys that make like
a headline female hero the analysis we
have is sorry all you Wonder Woman fans
the closest we have to a headline female
characters Wonder Woman and she's not
really headline material
well like I have yet to read a Wonder
Woman book that I liked exactly it's
like a feminine book or anything like
that it's just they've never put her in
a good situation
no azarello like it does they're doing
something cool I will acknowledge that
like the things that do with the water
moon book are not typical they're not
like obvious which I really appreciate
I liked Wonder Woman oh why I love her
character but I've read the first three
to new 52 Wonderland besides like oh
this is a really good way to jump in it
just wasn't for me no yeah it has a
thing kind of feel that saga gave and it
just it just isn't for me but I really
loved one a woman add the supporting
character I love her in the Justice
League yeah oh no I agree then I don't
like I don't like soullow Superman books
but I love him in the Justice League or
at a cameo appearance I'm not a fan of
him in his solo book that latest run
with John for meto junior or whatever
his name is I
I'm a junior right leave me alone but
either way his latest run I'm not liking
the whole I found someone in my similar
situation and he'll learn how to be a
superhero I'm like yeah I was a passive
wonderful no be a good movie if they
make it kinda like 300 what the chick
III think I think that would be a really
really solid movie I think honestly what
they need to do is do it right though
because if we get the Wonder Woman movie
adjustments half the movie in our
underwear it's just you've gone in the
wrong direction and the fact that the
people in charge of it are the same guys
that think that she Hulk it's just the
Hulk's sex toy makes me wonder woman
that is blade to writer David Goyer a
woman with his Dark Knight trilogy that
he's never read a comic book in his life
right so yeah except for the Jeph Loeb
books which he'd completely stole from
but aside from that I don't know anyone
in the world who ever thought that she
Hulk was a sex toy or the home that is
that is like Tim Burton talking about
comics is somebody who clearly knows
nothing about what they're talking about
you know you know what I know somebody
thinks that Rob does and we can bash on
Rob cuz he's not here I'm gonna get away
from that okay so we've gone off topic
yeah who's afraid of actually black
panther because he doesn't have a book
so I don't even know his primary villain
it is cool man
occasionally what's it why like it's
like a six-issue miniseries it's funny
like a big part of black panther
recently within the last like eight
years has been his marriage to storm and
that being like a big like character
moment for him and people seem to like
seeing the two of them together and it's
cool to see storm like participating in
what condon affairs and stuff like that
all right it's been annulled since AVX
but like whatever I love how they did it
though we're gonna be a different size I
know the marriage is over killing his
people and then she shows up to help and
he's like our marriage
old by the high priest of Wakanda and
she's like you're the high priest of
Wakanda and he's like please leave my
computer is going to die and ten minutes
okay I'm just letting you guys know that
right now I'm not trying to be a douche
no not at all that I got the red blankie
like okay oh you wanted it real quick I
do want to try that oh no I mean like no
me like my actual computer is going to
die I'm oh my laptop okay oh let's let's
let's run it out let's do the next day
okay no I said oh it is you are you are
oh okay well guys I'm clueless on this
but who do you thinks gonna be the
villain of Avengers infinity war the
dark side don't ya dark side I am
looking forward to being red cool that
would be awesome what a loop ready folks
Oh somebody's like look what I found
there's a big there's a lot of people
who think that Andy Serkis is gonna play
claw in Avengers 2 uh so maybe we'll see
more claw I don't know I'd be really
happy to see like Marvel paid Fox much
money and see Doctor Doom be a bad guy
that's not gonna happen like disagree
vanity that we might get Andrew Garfield
spider-man yeah I'm okay with that right
yeah yeah I get just one scene of the
iron spider suit or just make my life
that's that's a lot but I think it's a
tall order but I think they can deliver
it I know I if they do that I would have
to change my pants twice in one for
[ __ ] in them and I would be so happy
to be sitting in his own filth like that
was amazing the title of the episode
Drake sitting in his own filth it's long
but isn't likely to work yeah Sony's
definitely like we're done we can't we
don't know what they're doing they're
gonna give us Andrew Garfield
spider-man forward the movies ya know
the reboot
spider-man a few years other yeah um
villain wise what do you guys know let's
try to get this last one before we lose
Drake Captain Marvel in Inhumans villain
what you guys thinkin uh I mean like for
Captain Marvel I don't know being stolen
I think the Inhumans are gonna be just
they're inhuman Civil War Black Bolt
versus the other side of the family
doesn't that's going on in the comics
right now yeah okay cool
honestly I don't know why Captain Marvel
I just picked up her first trade from
2013 and she's in World War two so I
can't really know the comics Captain
Marvel like there's no real villain with
a lot of more recent comics they're not
giving us any real powerful villains
yeah and I think in humans will be
Maximus the mad well that's what else
they get another be inhuman Civil War to
be Maximus the mad yeah as long as we
get lockjaw and I'm happy yeah out of
here per I don't care about the Inhumans
at all so I don't I don't care like it's
yeah what's wrong with you down my
throat and I'm like stop I don't care
books just because they like humans like
it's not gonna stop trying to make
Inhumans okay that's all I want the dog
your job whenever they make the Miss
Marvel movie that they're so obviously
gonna be yeah I though when they
announced that I'm gonna do that he was
right comicdrake was right right here's
the episode clicking ok so says my
losing trailer Drake and we've kind of
gone through all the movement Ari
no problem at all this is we're lucky we
were able to knock this out um next week
we hope to have Rob back in the show
guys and we'll be streaming this in the
proper location which is youtube.com
backslash Marvel explained as usual I'm
Benny for comics Torian that is Sal 40v
little house
that is trailer Drake for comicdrake
nama trailers week whatever you want to
call me or subscribe to but if you guys
want me back let them know and they
might actually think I'm not so terrible
person no I will try to get his internet
fixed up so he doesn't look like a big
blob you know I'll make sure to bring a
charger with me but seriously if you
guys on my back let him know and I'd be
more than happy to come back I'm more
than happy about talking about comics
awesome what I do every day we're gonna
end this right now but you're going to
get some additional stuff with me and
Sal I'm just trying to close out what
we're discussing with Drake here since
we're gonna lose them so we have an
official closeout yeah there we go so um
a drink you want to just tell them what
your channel is all about what you're
gonna be brought to the YouTube avengers
Alliance
then wait real quick I do have to state
that was that was not coined by me that
was coined by Twitter account monster
moment he called us the YouTube Avengers
so okay I'm cool I'm cool with that so
yeah my main account is a trailer Drake
I post some popular opinions about
popular video games cuz I'm that [ __ ]
I click reviews I do a couple other
things but I'm not making any new videos
for this new channel yet but expect more
of those either when this hits a
thousand subscribers or in January
that's gonna be more I'm gonna try to be
the newcomers best friend to the comic
book world I'm gonna try to help explain
where to jump in on Marvel word hasn't
been on DC what image comics are good so
I'm gonna try to do that don't expect
anything just yet if you want to
subscribe and see some other random
comic book stuff I'm not gonna say no it
sounds great oh he'll be joining us I
believe his big first Bush is gonna be
around January when our top secret
Avengers project that in there I like it
long as I'm still Black Widow yeah you
can still be like what on the Secret
Avengers it's fine yeah alright but I'm
gonna go from Iron Man to Spider Woman
so we'll just okay okay okay that's cool
that's where the big secret thing was
cuz lvl 60 but our super party's gonna
launch on January 1st
along with comic Drake's official launch
although I think he's so amped up he's
just gonna start putting stuff out now
so I honestly I might
I have like five scripts all ready to go
and you're gonna launch it like Google
does you're gonna launch
like a year in advance and then have the
official launch yeah exactly I might
actually do that anyone who's wondering
where that joke comes from if you didn't
if you weren't aware of it Gmail is
technically in beta still yeah so okay I
guess we'll end it will technically end
the Marvel explained version of this and
we'll close it out right here so thank
you so much for joining us to by the way
you've just now cleared up Drake now
we're good to see you but thank you so
much for joining us and I will talk to
you a little bit later all right now you
can close it officially and yeah yeah
thanks editors yes this is it so thank
you guys for Mike we'll see you guys
next week
blah whipped I'm closing the stream now
so second go charge it was gonna say all
right now we're gonna kill one so bye
guys appreciated